[Music]
hello everybody my name is Vitaly namer
and I'm the Grand Master resident here
the Chess Club the same - is just on the
best chess club in the world at the
capital of the world world
whoop-whoop today is Sunday and we are
in paradise
yay puzzles paradise that's all what we
need in Paradise just some puzzles okay
here let's look at this position today
today the topic is going to be
sufficient Zog which means in German it
means in between moves move in between
moves those those are the moves that we
don't expect them it's a much much more
difficult for us to calculate because
usually when somebody let's say somebody
takes a piece one of our pieces we
immediately capture or we immediately
would do something but we always we
sometimes forget about those in-between
moves that might be winning the game for
us so there are a few types of
in-between moves there are in between
checks there are in between made threats
there are in between Queen attacks there
are promotion based sufficient Zerg and
there are unusual sufficient zone now I
dare you to say specials expressions of
20 times fast yeah good luck with that
okay so this is position number one this
is just gonna be a warm-up in this
position it was black to move black
played this move Bishop to g4 attacking
the White Queen on d1 it looks like
White has upon up in this position but
he all he needs to do is just to castle
and white just played f3 so far White
was pretty happy with this position he
said okay well the bishop has to go back
and then
I might play something like Bishop f4 or
Bishop g5 and then okay maybe I'll
castlelong or maybe I will even play c5
next move so Bishop e6 if Bishop e6 then
c5 and I can just scan so short and my
life is beautiful as we say however
black has found a very very strong
tactic in this position now before we
begin the number one forcing line which
we will we would calculate in this
position would be for example Bishop
takes f3 Bishop takes f3 Knight x f3
check Queen takes f3 and queen two takes
on d6 so far looks perfect we gather
piece back we get a pass excuse me we
got a pawn back and black looks super
duper good but unfortunately as we as I
always recommend always calculate half a
move ahead never stop in at a variation
and at this point everybody can see that
white can White's plan was to play this
sneaky move c5 and just take the bishop
and win the game so this was white
sneaky plan
unfortunately black knew about this
principle of sufficient circle so let's
see who can find here black blue and
black to win in this position take your
time you're going to have only one
option only one option to give your
answer in those in those lectures it's
all about the quality not about the
quantity let me try to flip the board by
the way if it's black to move okay
wherever suggestions here Knight takes
on c4 and if I take with a knight
okay so Knight takes Queen takes Knight
takes and right now you are exactly in a
knight disadvantage this game was played
in between sing and sajo in 1994 in a
place called cocky coda different
policies correctly yes please fish up to
c7 interesting I'm going to take on b7
Knight takes
Knight takes f3 interesting the bishop
takes and the bishop takes that actually
doesn't does not look so so bad so I'll
take my words back so Bishop c7 is an
interesting move how do i punish you how
they punish you for this
passive move going backwards was it I
hate going backwards never retreat
Bishop c7 I'm gonna first of all I can
just take on g4 probably you can take on
d6 then I can cancel you know you'll
probably get a pawn back on g4 another
idea that I have in mind is after Bishop
c7 is to play c5 so kind of following
that that that the same line so Bishop
c75 and if you take on d6 I'll take with
the pawn still you have to waste some
time to move your Bishop f ing for make
sense all right good good idea so the
first move that was played by black was
Bishop takes f3 pretty forcing right one
of the forcing variations
well obviously Bishop has to take enough
thing otherwise everything is hanging
the queen is hanging here on d1 and now
ladies and gentlemen we are in a
sufficient zouk let's try to find out
the in-between moves we do not take the
bishop out after he wouldn't attack the
knight on d6 f2 is weak right now black
is gonna make him a move and exploiting
a fork trick an exploding move yes the
gentleman in the back Bishop to d4 BAM
oh my god if I would see it on the chess
board I would get a heart attack as
white Bishop to d4 what is the idea I
block the connection between the Quinlan
and the night I want to take this 96 I
want to take this knife with it with it
with a fork on the Rockland
the king what can I do here what can I
do
exactly so the problem for white is that
if it takes with the Queen and before
now that f3 is going to drop the Queen
sayonara
so Bishop to d4 and why just designs I
mean there's no there's nothing can do
even if you defend this night oh I'll
take I'll take this night or I'll take
this special first and your piece down
still without the castle and hopeless
this is the power of this vicious
efficient Zerg yes
now try if you cannot pronounce that try
to spell it luckily we have Google today
and Google Translate okay let's go int
into an exposition now let's go to some
positions I can find out from real games
this was also from a game and was played
by between ain't goin against van Valley
so as we said that we have five kinds of
submissions oops the first one was in
between checks so we are going to look
at some positions about this topic in
between checks
of the ready defense or English
I'm fast forwarding to the position
so far looks pretty equal okay seven
nice invasion c4 queen g4 and now King
f8 you wanted to defend the defender
Bishop Bishop e3 and Bishop to c5 okay
white to move basically but black wanted
is 2y to take on c5 Queen takes on c5
and simplify the position by exchanging
a few pieces the queen is gonna attack
the ryokan a7 also the King's gonna
attack the pawn on e5 but look forgot
about this vision look okay I think two
people already know from the crowd let's
let's see if I'll give a few minutes for
our viewers at home to solve this if you
can't follow us so quickly you can pause
the video why to move and to win a piece
okay I think it's time for a small hint
for the people who already solved it
perfect that's very good
a small hint we want to look at blacks
weak spots where are his weak spots then
Bishop here on g5 is definitely attacked
another weak spot is this pawn on f7 and
kind of the queen is a bit shaky usually
we don't we don't pay attention to the
Queen because we think all the Queen is
so great she's all can do but no the
Queen is actually sometimes also pretty
shaky so this are the three squares the
black should be concerned about okay so
I think you are the first one young
gentleman in the back Queen to f3 we
have two pieces were attacking right now
the rook and
and the bishop attacking some squares so
we have to involve some some other
pieces in the game so it will be either
the rook on f1 or the Queen's of the
Queen - eye to eye
the Queen here on the on c6 and the tack
the pollen of seven days Queen to f3
just a silent innocent move attacking
out of seven attacking the Queen
obviously the Queen has to make up your
mind do I defend from there mate well
actually the Queen cannot go anywhere to
defend on the mate except just taking
the Queen here but now we have this
vision look the bishop takes on c5 check
King moves and we take the Queen and
black resigns so even a supergiant
master one of the top can mess those
look one very sometimes misses one of
those in between moves happens to
everybody
happens to everybody okay next one next
game will be between can somebody put
out the whites whites name lamb Soren me
ago what's wrong okay I know how Toby's
guy I know the other guy I guess
hopefully upon us is his name correctly
we have still the same topic in between
chat box so let's get to the to the game
to the position we had the four Knights
over here this in between moves actually
went to an endgame the interesting looks
pretty equal looks pretty equal and now
d5 was the move played by black and
disposition and it is white to move the
exposition might seem a bit better
because of the opponent f2 which is
might be weak so if we exchange all the
all the pieces Bishop takes a 5 volt
takes a 5 hook takes a 5 volt XL v then
this pawn of two might become a bit weak
although it might also become a pretty
strong passer however white finds a very
strong
swishing good idea I see some hands
going up but I see them kind of like I'm
sure maybe yeah I go slowly okay I'm not
sure who was the first one so I'll just
give it to you can rook to e1 okay
and what happens if I just take the rope
okay rook takes yeah so if we think they
work on f5 that gives them time to move
with the rock now you're still in a good
shape because you wanna take the d5
phone but it might become very
complicated game after rook h1 Rudi 5
take take take King III and if I if I go
hook up 7 here then I think black is
supposed to be fine
maybe wife has a better better chance in
someone and making some in between moves
to take those pawns away but you need
some do you need some polishing all
right good job Isaac so rook to e1 is
the correct move because we basically
can see those weak squares on f5 and ef5
they're kind of hanging rook e1 was
plate black does need to take the rook
don't see any other chance for black but
now instead of taking on a fight with
the bishop as we tried white to kill
with the rook rope takes on f5 and the
whole idea is that if the what a black
hook goes anywhere it's a eight or a
seven then we take it this rook with a
check and we are piece up and this is
pretty much it so rook takes on a5 and
if it takes a look on a5 then Bishop
takes on a5 that's all in between moves
move and King takes on Yvonne
with a with a piece up
good job guys teamwork let's see the
next one next one we have flooring Yoga
against Wolfgang almond okay it's still
on the same topic still on the topic of
in between checks check moves again we
are going to be playing white
fast-forwarding to our interesting
position looks like the way we had a few
sacrifices here
okay fast forwarding to this position
looks like blacks last move was rook
takes on their fate and now ladies and
gentlemen why to move
I have to warn you that if you do see a
in-between idea in this in this puzzle
white is the exhibition zhuge in mine
but black also has a sufficient second
mind this position of the twin is never
good never never place you Quinn in the
front of the bishop like this very
dangerous
okay I think you're the first one yes
please uh-huh and if the Queen takes on
e4 so you take my night I take your rook
and I'll take you Queen you're getting
close you're getting close but let's see
some somebody else
all right something yes please wrote to
g4 first of all interesting rule g4 and
if I take on e6 Queen takes c6
okay anybody else all right Isaac again
takes Bravo Queen takes f6 that's the
correct move and now black cannot take
on f6 because of the check here so we
know that that's losing pretty easily
losing the Queen Queen takes e4 suddenly
black comes up with his new solutions in
between move now if we take the Queen
then we're losing our queen and probably
losing the game however black said white
says not so fast I have another move for
you Queen takes f7 check it's probably
important by the way to take with a
queen and not with the pawn because if
we takes with the pawn then the King
just can just move away so Queen takes
f7 is amol forcing line rook has to take
context with the check King takes and
finally bishop takes on e4 nice sec yes
good job let's go to our next position
which is going to be about the
in-between mate threats so why to move
and win the game
I think you're the first one yeah please
Queen h4 and if Knight h5 pretty much
for us to do this
okay so think about this okay anybody
else yes please Knight to g6 okay
interesting so the idea is to checkmate
with a rook on h8 a checkmate or they
trade black cannot take the night
because of Queen takes c6 check King f8
and wrote to h8 and it's a checkmate on
g8 all right so black had to play this
move Knight to h7 so how to post it here
laughs tonight to h7 okay okay Adi what
do you think if King takes and if if I
take the unite it's the only variation I
might survive very good good job buddy
we will take six seven I want to make
him again
King Tate it takes h7 Queen takes h4
check King to g6 again I cannot go to
jail because of the checkmate on h8 and
now the quiet move g4 yeah so it's yeah
so now Queen h5 is a threat with a
checkmate black played Bishop takes on
g5 and now the most precise way to
checkmate here is
say it again okay now I heard it
correctly Quinte sg5 checkmate very good
okay this one is a game between our one
of our players here in the United States
Picaro Nakamura versus a guy his name is
Colleen
Kaleo Budapest 2002 and you are actually
going to try to beat Nakamura get ready
for this not too much is going on in the
opening
my camo made a pretty good attack with
white looks like his better
lots of maneuvering going on check
the good thing about following a game is
that I cannot mess up the position
Bishop to d8 was played we still have a
few more in front of us
and Bishop to 80 that's how we got to
the position it is black to move mm try
to calculate this as far as possible to
get the foot to get the full amount of
points yes please
that's correct very good he probably
needs to take her to the pond
I've been if the Queen takes h8 Kingi
one
six okay Rock f2
you can check on d1 but then I have
bishop f1 still looks like I'm holding
but the first move nigt is correct but
now this is what the the variation that
Nakamura calculated probably but black
has a very strong in-between move here
yes correct
Bishop to b6 is the cracker so again if
I take you on g3 Queen takes check Kim
Ji Won they should be six check look up
to Queen d1 check and it looks like
white almost escaping his destined
sentence
so Bishop to b6 is the correct move
first we we do this move now if if Queen
e1 now let's say this then pawn takes on
on g3 now trapping a checkmate on h8 and
there's really no ways for Y to stop
that and if you play is Bishop to c5
then now we take on the on g3 again
Quinta GT is not possible now because
the bishop is hanging for example this
variation check and now we're gonna be
up in material if they're just
exchanging here and if the Queen moves
somewhere let's say Queen - III then
check came to g1 and let's see who can
find the last move in the combination
a monstrous surprise the definition of
the next move
yes please Queen d6 and if I take the
bishop you're getting close the prowess
is what if I don't take your queen you
have to make a more useful over the
Queen
that was a big hint I'm also blinking
Abby go into d4 and if the Queen takes
will be a bunch of exchanges and what I
think I can actually write the hill
bishop and your Bishop down
remember your P's done right now
yes Queen d2 again I'm going to take the
bishop which one
right queen is seven yes that is yes so
attacking the bishop on c5 now if I take
the Queen then it's going to be probably
and it's some kind of a checkmate here
and then I'm gonna bring in there okay
and I know each one so this is pretty
much winning and if the bishop takes
bishop now then the idea is to bring the
Queen to h4 and that is it there is no
defense against checkmate now this is
the fourth one this is the fall style
this is the sufficient zhuge on
promotion based promotion based
submissions look in between move
hopefully I will not go too far in this
one
we're actually going to get into an
endgame
here we go I will stop over here is
white to move yes please
hopefully everybody followed good job
that was very fast wrote the FA check
that's the correct move the King cannot
move to h7 because of Queen to g6
checkmate so black has to take the rook
on on their fate but instead of taking
justly capturing the rook we have an
in-between move Queen to d5 check again
if the King moves to h8 well we can take
him out to a queen of the check however
in the game black played King - h7 now
if we take on on their faith and promote
the Queen then we're going to get check
mated in one move so there so the idea
here the beauty is that we promote but
to a knight yes so luckily we don't have
outer promotion to the Queen in over the
board games not like in bullet games
night here and the King has to go to h8
and now is a checkmate or move Knight to
g6 good job the last one at least are
the fifth kind that we have and this is
going to be the unusual sufficiency of
moves not checks and that kept not
captures but very very unusual so let's
get to the action we see a French
defense one of the main lines we never
and black just play this movie for wants
to exchange Queens and then attacking
our bishop on d3 okay let's get into
Bobby's mind if you were Bobby Fischer
how would I play here that's a pretty
tough one just to give you a small hint
right now we have material equality
white has two bishops but like has a
very strong Center
so basically Bobby finds a way how to
get a pawn advantage which is enough for
him to win the game I'm not gonna go
look at all of the game but he finds out
how to get a pawn advantage obviously if
the bishop escapes somewhere then we
lose the seat upon the exchanges
exchanges the Queen's first and then you
can take on c2 so moving backwards is
not an option so the first move has to
be anybody has an idea yes please
close
first of all is rook takes e4 now first
of all black cannot take only for
because of Bishop f4 to take me Bishop
f4 but black can make a swishing Zerg
Queen takes to g3 and now the question
is now comes the more beautiful move
obviously if we just take the Queen then
we goes there okay and the game is lost
yes please rook takes d4
where can a king the Queen go
that's a very unusual move so now the
game continues with Queen to g4 and then
they transpose in such and such an
endgame but those two bishops especially
this pawn on f6 was very very strong and
eventually white won the game you gotta
be special just as you are can yes
please yes you can and then we probably
going to take with a pawn I would say or
with a rook but I would say with the
pawn and now we are pawn up that's
that's what I thought is gonna happen
and then now we upon up again with this
this this pawn is very dangerous I'm
attacking on d5 Black has slim chances
for a draw but I would say with the
correct accurate game I could play white
will have the upper hand okay guys thank
you for joining me today and hopefully
we go
[Music]
you
[Music]